CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I'd like us to
work on the following problem.
What values of b will make
this vector field F a gradient
field, where F is determined by
e to the x plus y times x plus
b i plus x*j?
So the e to the x plus y is in
both the i component and the j
component.
And then once you've determined
what values b will make that
a gradient field, for this
b-- or I should've said these
b's-- find a potential function
f using both methods from
the lecture.
So why don't you pause
the video, work on this,
and then when you are
ready to look at how I
do it bring the video back up.
OK.
Welcome back.
So I'm going to
start off working
on the first part of
this problem, which
is to find the values of b that
will make this vector field
F a gradient field.
And to clarify
things for myself,
I'm going to write down what M
and what N are based on F. So
just to have it
clear, M is equal to e
to the x plus y times x plus
b and N is equal to x times
e to the x plus y.
So those are our
values for M and N.
And now if I want f to
be a gradient field, what
I have to do is I have to
have M sub y equal N sub x.
So I'm going to
determine M sub y
and I'm going to
determine N sub x
and I'm going to compare them
and see what value of b I get.
So M sub y, fairly
straightforward because this
is a constant in y.
And the derivative of this in
terms of y is just this back.
Right?
It's an exponential
function with the value
that it has in y is linear.
So you get exactly
that thing back.
So it actually is just e to
the x plus y times x plus b.
So the derivative of M
sub y is just itself.
The derivative of M with
respect to y, sorry.
Not the derivative of M sub y.
OK.
That's an x.
Let me just rewrite that.
OK, now N sub x is
going to have two parts.
N sub x, the derivative with
respect to x of this is 1.
And so I have an
e to the x plus y.
And the derivative with respect
to x of e to the x plus y
is just e to the plus
y, for the same reason
as the derivative with
respect to y was the same.
So then I'm just going to get
a plus x e to the x plus y.
So that means if I factor that
out, I get an e to the x plus y
times 1 plus x.
And we see that if F is going
to be a gradient field then
b has to equal 1.
Because it can only have one
value, and so b has to equal 1.
To get N sub x to equal M
sub y, b has to equal 1.
So now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to erase that b,
put in a 1, so that the rest of
my calculations refer to that.
So now the second
part said for this
b find a potential function
f using both methods
from the lecture.
So we're going to go
through both methods
and hopefully we get the
same answer both times.
So let me come back here.
The first method is where
I'm integrating along a curve
from (0, 0) to (x_1, y_1).
So I'm going to do it
in the following way.
I'm going to let C_1--
so here's (0, 0)--
I'm going to let C_1 be the
curve from (0, 0) up to (0,
y_1).
And then C_2 be the curve--
so it's parameterized
in that direction-- C_2 be
the curve from (0, y_1) to
(x_1, y_1).
OK?
So that's what I'm
going to do, and I'm
going to let C equal
the curve C_1 plus C_2.
So I'm going to have
C be the full curve.
And what I'm interested in
doing is finding f of x_1,
y_1, which will just equal the
integral along C of F dot dr.
So now we need to figure
out some important things
about C_1 and C_2.
What's happening on C_1 and
what's happening on C_2.
And the first thing I want
to point out-- actually,
before I do that, let me remind
you that this is going to be
the integral on C
of M*dx plus N*dy.
So this will be helpful
to refer back to.
That's really what
we're also doing here.
So on C_1, what do I notice?
On C_1, x is 0 and dx is 0.
And y goes between 0 and y_1.
And then on C_2,
y is equal to y_1.
So dy is equal to 0 and x
is going between 0 and x_1.
So those are the values
that are important to me.
So if you notice from
this fact and this fact,
we see that if we look at
the integral just along C_1,
there's going to
be no M*dx term.
And if we look at the
integral along C_2,
there's going to be no
dy term because of that.
So let me write down
the terms that do
exist, and we'll see some
other things drop out also.
If I look along
first just C_1, I'm
only going to get-- I said
the dy term, which-- let
me just make sure-- dx is 0.
I'm only going to get the
dy term, which is-- well,
x is 0 there.
So I'm going to get 0 times
e to the 0 plus y, dy.
From 0 to y_1.
Well that's nice and easy to
calculate, thank goodness.
That's just 0.
So all I have to do for this
one is just leave it at 0.
That's everything that
happens along C_1.
That's what I'm interested in.
I just get 0 there.
And if I integrate along
C_2, as I mentioned, dy is 0.
So we don't have any
component with N*dy.
We just have the component
M*dx that we're integrating.
OK, so if I integrate along
C_2, I just have M*dx and M is e
to the x plus y times x plus 1.
And y is fixed at y_1.
So it's e to the x plus
y1 times x plus 1 dx.
And I'm going from 0 to x_1.
I'm going to make sure I
didn't make any mistakes.
I'm going to check my work here.
Yes, I'm looking good.
OK.
So this one is 0.
So all I have to do is find
an antiderivative of this.
And the term-- if
I multiply through,
I see that here I get
exactly the same thing when
I look for an antiderivative.
And here I get, I
believe, two terms when
I look for an antiderivative.
But I'm going to get
some cancellation.
And ultimately, when I'm all
done I'm going to get this.
x e to the x plus y_1
evaluated at 0 and x_1.
You could do this.
This is really now a
single variable problem.
So I'm not going to work
out all the details,
but you might want
to do an integration
by parts on that first
part of it, if that helps.
Or an integration by
parts on the whole thing.
That would also do the trick.
So what do I get here?
Then I get x_1 e to
the x_1 plus y_1.
And then when I put in 0 for
x here, I get 0, so that's it.
So this, plus possibly a
constant, is equal to my f.
So I see that in general I
get f of x, y is equal to x e
to the x plus y plus a constant.
So that's what I get
in the first method.
So now let's use
the second method.
So I should say f of x_1, y_1.
In the second method, what
I do is-- M, remember,
is equal to f sub x.
So f sub x is equal to
M which is equal to e
to the x plus y times x plus 1.
So if I want to find
an antiderivative--
if I want to find f, I should
take an antiderivative, right?
With respect to x.
And so notice I already
did that, actually.
If I just put this as y,
I already did that here.
And so I should
get something that
looks like this: x
e to the x plus y
plus possibly a function
that only depends on y.
And the reason is when I take
a derivative with respect
to x of this, obviously
this would be 0.
So it doesn't show up over here.
So this, we make sure that-- oh,
that, I shouldn't write equals.
Sorry.
That, I shouldn't write equals.
OK?
This would imply that
this is equal to f.
Sorry about that.
f sub x was equal to
M was equal to this.
That implies-- when I take
an antiderivative of an x--
that x e to the x plus y
plus g of y is equal to f.
So I apologize.
That wouldn't have been an
equals because obviously
those two things are not equal.
That would imply,
I think-- yeah,
that would imply something
very bad mathematically.
So make sure you understand
I put an equals sign where
I should not have.
This is actually a
derivative of that.
So this is
antiderivative of this.
So now I have a candidate for f.
And so now I'm going to
take the derivative of that.
And what's the derivative
of that with respect to y?
So f sub y based on this
is going to be equal to x e
to the x plus y
plus g prime of y.
So the prime here indicates
it's in a derivative in y.
And now that f sub y
should also equal N.
And N equals x e
to the x plus y.
So what do I get here?
I see x e to the x
plus y has to equal
x e to the x plus y
plus g prime of y.
Which means g prime
of y is equal to 0.
Which means when I take an
antiderivative of that I just
get a constant.
That means g of
y was a constant.
So that implies that this
boxed expression right here
is f of x, y if g of
y is just a constant.
So let me go through
that logic one more time.
I had f sub x.
I took an
antiderivative to get f
but it involved a constant in
x that was a function of y.
I take a derivative
of that in y.
I compare that to what I
know the derivative is in y.
That gives me that this is 0.
So its antiderivative, which
is g of y, is just a constant.
And so altogether this implies
that f of x, y is equal to x e
to the x plus y plus a constant.
Which is exactly
what I got before.
Fortunately, I got two
answers that are the same.
So that's it.
I'll stop there.